now it's your turn to implement the
functionality to set and get
announcements so first you're going to
need to define the announcement class
this is a very simple class it just
basically has one field message and the
constructor needs to take the message
and put it in the message field we need
this class only because the endpoint
functions must return an object with the
field rather than a string and you're
going to need to implement the set
announcement servlet you have to
implement the do get method you'll need
to get the memcache service you'll
actually have to write the logic to
construct the announcement and then
you're going to need to put the
announcement in memcache keyed off the
recent announcements key and then don't
forget to configure your servlet in
web.xml there's a skeleton
implementation of set announcement
servlet available for you if you'd like
to use it and you can find that in the
lesson 5 folder you're also welcome to
create it from scratch if you want then
in the conference API class you need to
add the get announcement function which
is an endpoint function which gets the
announcement out of memcache and returns
it as an announcement object now after
you've tested it and it's working on
localhost go ahead and deploy it to
appspot
and then you go to cron slash set
underscore announcement to actually run
the set announcement function and again
the web browsers not going to change
whatever it's showing when you go to
this URL it'll continue to show after
execute the function then in the api's
explorer you can test the get
announcement function to get the values
of the announcement out of memcache and
then use memcache viewer to check that
your announcements are in memcache
obviously they will be if get
announcement works but it's good to
practice using the memcache viewer and
you can actually get the value of the
entry that's keyed by recent
announcements so go ahead and do that
and then when everything's working on
your app deployed on appspot
go ahead and enter your app ID here as
you're testing the get and set
announcement functions you're going to
obviously need to make sure that you
have some conferences where the seats
available is between 0 & 5 otherwise you
won't get any results and you won't get
any announcements saved